this episode of the Y files is brought
to you by PDS
de since grade school we've been taught
that gravity is what keeps our feet
firmly planted on the ground but what if
that's all been a lie now I'm not saying
if you jump off a bridge you fall up
instead of down but what if Newton and
Einstein were wrong and what really ties
our universe together is not gravity but
electricity the electric universe theory
says that instead of gravity the
universe's true attractive Force comes
from invisible electric currents that
surround our planet our solar system the
Galaxy and everything we're all living
in one giant Universe spanning circuit
mainstream science ignores this
possibility but ignoring the electric
Universe blinds us to an unknown risk
the myths of our ancestors describe
cataclysmic Global disasters in the
distant past they knew about the
electric Universe 2 not from science but
from experience and our ancestors have
sent us a strange but dire warning
beware the shocking Fury of planet
[Music]
Saturn ah human you listen I know you've
been hesitant to invest in my businesses
before but uh I don't think the words no
way in hell am I investing in your
hairbrain scheme can be construed as
hesitation just hear me out okay so uh
things are super expensive right now
right right and I'm spending a fortune
on Uber going back and forth to the
studio to host a show uh first off I
host the show ah you say
potato hey is Gertie in a tunnel I'm I'm
hearing Echoes I'm getting to that I'm
so frustrated with making my payments on
everything every month and my balances
never go down I need to make some extra
scratch Jack so I have come up with an
amazing business idea all I need from
you is a teeny tiny investment how tiny
oh just a teeny weeny Teensy weny teeny
tiny how much 50 Grand
$50,000 I don't even need to hear the
idea to tell you my answer excellent I
knew I could count on you human no no no
no that's not what I said you're now
going to be the proud partner of the
brand new camel ride share app
hump humped yeah don't you love it I can
pict you the commercials Now traffic in
you out you need to get humped
frustrated by high gas prices just get
humped yeah I don't know if that's
really no it's perfect now we just need
to get camel lowjack GPS and a whole
bunch of leather leather on a camel oh
yeah Gertie loves leather don't you baby
yes you do yes you do it's my baby girl
I'm so uncomfortable right now H we also
need to get a custom riding crop for
each camel riding crop ah it's a small
whip to tell the camel to go faster I
know what it is isn't using a crop going
to hurt the camel not through the
leather it won't no dear besides it was
Gertie's idea she doesn't mind a little
hanky Spanky please stop telling me
about this idea right now so I need a
marketing budget hats t-shirts
Billboards can you picture it a huge
billboard by the freeway there's Gertie
covered in Supple leather riding cop
between her teeth and in giant letters
get
humped yeah that's not going to I don't
I look would you just call PDS they can
help you with your debt no app no camels
and no leather needed
PDS I was that today sponsor what gave
you that idea PDS has options for anyone
struggling with monthly debt payments
credit cards personal loans collections
medical bills everyone with over $10,000
or more in eligible debt qualifies yeah
but my credit is in a toilet there's no
minimum credit score required bad and
Fair Credit is accepted they roll your
debt into one low 0% interest monthly
payment you could save thousands in
interest and fees and pay off your debt
in a fraction of the time YY and PDS is
giving our qualified viewers a free debt
analysis just for completing the 30C
online assessment at www. pdsd
bt.com files it's pdsd
ebt.com files that's it okay I'll go
sign up now but I need you to stop at
the store and pick up 250 lb of camel
Chow a case of champagne and the 50
Shades a great box set yeah there's just
no way wait 250 lb of camel Chow that's
way more than Gertie eats I know you
her cousins are coming into town
to help with the business Gertie can't
give all these rides herself her hump
can only take so much damage don't worry
they'll only be with you a couple of
months with me you better said you could
stay I absolutely did no go get out
everybody get in the mood get in the
nude and get in the pool let's get
[Music]
HED standard cosmological Theory says
that the Universe was created during the
big
[Music]
bang for 400,000 years after the big
bang the universe was mostly hydrogen
and helium just floating around then
gravity started to pull matter into
bundles that became Stars gravity pulled
Stars into galaxies gravity pulled
galaxies into clusters after that
Supernova explode and the universe is
sprinkled with elements gravity causes
these elements to coales into planets
those planets fall into regular orbits
around their stars and here we are all
thanks to gravity the current theory of
gravity was proposed by Albert Einstein
through his work on General and special
relativity published in 1915 but there's
a problem with this Theory and Einstein
knew
it gravity isn't strong enough to keep
all this stuff in place especially on a
large scale given the amount of matter
spinning around a Galaxy and how fast
it's moving everything should fly apart
but it doesn't so what's holding
everything in place well officially it's
dark matter which you've heard of but
here's a little secret about dark matter
that they don't tell us
there's no proof it exists dark matter
is just a theory that's used as a
Band-Aid to explain the gravity
problem but maybe there's something else
happening maybe our universe isn't held
together by gravity it's held together
by electricity the electric universe
theory says that permeating space is a
vast sea of ionized particles these
particles create an enormous field of
plasma plasma is the fourth state of
matter the others being solid liquid and
gas not only is our sun mostly plasma
plasma makes up over
99.9% of the visible Universe this
network of plasma is so massive that it
connects every galaxy in the universe in
a single electric circuit this circuit
not only conducts electricity over great
distances but it transmits it faster
than light much
faster if the electric universe theory
is true it will change everything we
know about physics and reframe our
understanding of the cosmos but what
evidence is there electric cosmologists
have recently begun testing their
theories in the lab and have produced
surprising results but the real proof
may not be found in cosmology but
archaeology the electric universe theory
says that at one time our night sky was
a tapestry of glowing plasma but then a
drastic Cosmic event changed our Sky
forever our ancestors recorded this
event in customs and in myths and
symbology but changes to the sky weren't
the only thing that they described
hidden among the symbols is the record
of a catastrophe one that's left scars
across not just the Earth but every
planet in the solar
[Music]
system the Grand Canyon is one of the
most iconic places in the world the
Colorado River Flows between the canyon
walls and according to mainstream
geology it was formed through a complex
series of tectonic events and erosion
but if you look closely at the River
from overhead you'll notice its many
branches and tributaries split at very
odd but consistent angles this structure
is familiar to electrical cosmologists
many of whom are electrical engineers
the patterns look just like current
flowing through Electronics specifically
Junctions in the Colorado River follow
rules for an electrical circuit and
there's a reason for that even though
the universe is an ocean of electricity
we don't really see it because
everything stays pretty well balanced
just like you don't see electricity
flowing through a circuit that is until
something goes wrong and everything goes
haywire when the electrical balance of
the solar system is thrown off it leads
to Violent arcs that travel from planet
to planet and those arcs of current
leave scars across everything they touch
scars like the Grand Canyon on Earth or
the valis marineris on Mars geologists
say these canyons are formed by tectonic
activity and water erosion over millions
of years but electric cosmologists
believe unbelievable powerful lightning
creates the Canyons which are later
filled in by water the valis marineras
canyon which is as long as the entire
United States doesn't look like water
erosion it looks like something quickly
and violently gouged out a chunk of the
planet and parts of it have marks that
look exactly like tributaries in the
Grand Canyon or exactly like an enormous
bolt of lightning this entire region
resembles nothing so much as an area
Zapped by a powerful electric Arc
advancing unsteadily across the surface
these canyons are on rocky planets and
moons all over the solar system from
Venus all the way to Pluto and Beyond
what about Uranus what now are there any
scars on
Uranus Uranus has 27 moons its largest
moon Titania has a gash on it almost
1,000 M long wa something violent
happened near Uranus huh don't be an
[Laughter]
infant Electric cosmologists believe
that interplanetary lightning bolts have
hit the earth many times in the past
with dire consequences for everyone on
the
[Music]
planet goodness they believe there was a
catastrophic electrical event about
12,000 years ago survivors looked upon
the scarred landscape and copied what
they saw in hieroglyphics 12,000 years
ago is the time of the younger dras when
it said the Earth's ice caps melted
within a week causing a global cataclysm
this rapid melting of the ice caps
created tsunamis 1,000 ft high and
raised the Earth's sea level by hundreds
of feet at the end of that catastrophic
week the surface of the Earth would have
looked very different we know there was
a rapid warming of the earth after the
younger dras but nobody knows for sure
what caused it one theory is that it was
a giant asteroid impact another theory
is that the melting was caused by a
violent solar event like a solar flare
or coronal mass ejection but electric
cosmologists say the melting was caused
by a massive bolt of interplanetary
lightning that would definitely explain
it every culture on Earth has a flood
myth people living on every continent on
the planet have written stories and made
drawings of the global catastrophe all
scientific evidence says those myths are
true but those same myths describe the
night sky as looking very different than
it does today in the past the sun wasn't
the only prominent object in the sky and
our nearest planetary neighbor looked
much different today Venus is our
nearest planetary neighbor but in the
time of the myths Venus didn't exist yet
our nearest neighbor was Saturn Saturn
was so close to the Earth that this was
actually a binary Planet system but that
system didn't last forever and legends
tell the story of the time when Saturn
and the Earth parted ways and when that
happened all hell broke loose
when Emanuel velikovsky released his
best-selling book worlds in Collision he
turned astronomy on its
head it is only wishful thinking that we
are living in
a
safe never perturbed solar system and
the safe never per pered
us mainstream science says that our sky
is an orderly place that's looked the
same for millions of years but velkovski
found ancient evidence that tells a very
different story drakov's contention is
that in the memory of man the Earth has
gone through great natural
paroxysms he's founded his theory on the
ancient records of man from all over the
world on archaeological evidence in the
form of ancient calendars that have
become strangely obsolete and new and
radical interpretations of information
from astronomy paleontology
paleomagnetism and evolution velikovsky
used comparative mythology to examine
different Legends searching for common
themes besides the flood myth that all
cultures share belovsky found other
common Legends and the same story could
have
been found in Old places but differently
told so that it was no question of just
boring from one nation by
another so this was was the cusion the
story of human memory of catastrophes
that took place in historical times but
strangely despite the fact that they
were described in so many
sources as if nonexistent for the
scientific
World gods were often described as
immense celestial bodies presiding over
a mythical golden age where the planet
Saturn was the most important object in
the sky the Egyptians placed their
Creator God atum at the celestial pole
the axis around which the sky turned the
Babylonians said their supreme god Anu
ruled from the pole star but the pole
star wasn't a star at all the pole star
was
Saturn
the Greeks and Romans also identified
the planet Saturn as the Primeval Sun
God who reigned over a Lost Paradise the
archaic Latin name for Saturn was Soul
the sun in early Greek the planet Saturn
called Kronos was also named Helios the
sun France B was a German historian of
Science and his work is considered
foundational in astronomy he said Kronos
and Helios were at one time the same God
Saturn figures prominently in many
ancient texts astronomical history from
Greece Persia and China all claim Saturn
ruled the world the Golden Age was
called the reign of Saturn the original
site of Rome was known as saturnia The
Jewish Sabbath was Saturn's day popular
Roman festivals honored Saturn as the
father of the Gods dakovski thought this
was strange How could a distant planet
like Saturn be linked to the central
axis of the sky all of our ancient
Heritage that comes to us in terms of
architecture uh writing and so on
they're they're actually obsessed with
with the idea of worshiping these Stars
these dreaded planets uh All Mankind
through the years have uh uh worshiped
stars that we can't even pick out of the
sky today now why because in ancient
times Saturn was much closer to the
Earth and dominated the sky during this
time the Earth and Saturn were a binary
Planet system that together moved around
the sun because the two planets were
locked Saturn didn't rise or set it was
fixed in the sky just like the ancient
Egyptians said David talot continued the
work of ovsky he studied ancient symbols
from across the globe which described
how the sky once looked and it's very
different than the sky we now
know going back through prehistoric
times we see the same image in every
culture on every continent it's called
The Cosmic wheel the wheel was the
Throne of the Gods we see the wheel in
Buddhism jism and Hinduism the cosmic
wheel is seen in prehistoric Ireland and
in the hills of California across Africa
Scandinavia around the Mediterranean
Mexico Mesopotamia the image represents
three objects Saturn the large planet
farthest away a dark planet is closest
this was named Mars and in the middle a
glowing object the energy of the three
objects washed over the Earth the energy
gave humans lifespans of hundreds or
even thousands of years this time had
been called the Golden Age of Heroes
civilization
flourished but then something terrible
happened when electrical engineer wall
Thornhill saw one of David Talbot's
lectures on the cosmic wheel the design
was instantly recognizable to him so it
came as a bit of a shock and a surprise
to see David tber showing slides at one
of the sessions at the
conference which I recognized
immediately as being similar to those of
electric discharges in the
laboratory many ancient cultures
describe a golden age that ends with a
war between Gods leading to a
catastrophe on Earth myths around the
world tell of Mighty gods that ruled the
heavens this was an era of chaos and
each God vises for Supremacy one God
conquers another then the next God
conquers him and the favorite weapon of
the Gods the Thunderbolt in Hinduism the
mahabarata Tells Tales of a lost age
where Gods waged war on each other in
the sky using what can best be described
as energy weapons in Greek mythology the
god Zeus wielded a Celestial Thunderbolt
to wage war against the Titan Kronos in
Roman mythology Zeus was named Jupiter
and he was at war with Saturn the arrows
of Apollo the Trident of Neptune these
are all connected to
Thunderbolts so when our ancestors said
the gods waged war in the sky they were
interpreting actual Celestial
Thunderbolts that they witnessed jumping
between planets that they had named
after the gods but what caused this war
between the gods and the cataclysm on
Earth it was the glowing middle object
in the cosmic wheel Venus but Venus
didn't form like the other planets it
was created much more violently
a chunk of Jupiter was ejected from the
center of the planet this matter took
the form of a giant Comet this comet
would eventually become the planet Venus
and this event is also reflected in
Legends around the world the Greeks had
the myth of Zeus birthing the goddess
Athena from his forehead she emerged
fully grown and radiated brilliant light
she then uttered a cry that shook the
heavens and the Earth and remember
planets and gods are one and the same
and Zeus is Jupiter the Maya and
Babylonians had myths about Venus being
a fiery or blazing star just like a
comet the ancient Egyptians had a myth
about the Goddess Isis who was
associated with Venus she was
transformed into a fiery star that
descended to the Earth at some point the
Earth Venus Mars and Saturn drifted too
close to each other this led to massive
bolts of lightning between the planets
and this lightning blasted craters in
the moon and tore through the Earth to
create the Grand Canyon ancient cultures
recorded evidence of the lightning and
other plasma
discharges the Lasco cave in France has
cave art that's 177,000 years old these
images are extremely detailed very
realistic and very accurate so why does
later art become crude with men being
depicted as Stick Figures it's because
these are not drawings of men notice how
the arms always appear outstretched and
there are dots on either side of the
figure these are the same all over the
world so what is this the answer comes
from Anthony Pat a plasma physicist Pat
shows us an animation of a plasma
discharge the central column is the axis
around the axis is a Taurus or
donut-shaped ring of charged particles
the top is called a champagne glass the
bottom is called a squashed Bell to an
observer the shape is transparent but
there are places where the plasma is
most dense holy sh
this is the shape drawn by ancient
cultures around the world the reason
they recorded it is because they would
have seen this as a giant glowing object
in the sky like a god exactly these
plasma discharges would have been loud
and bright and violent and could have
easily been construed as Gods battling
in the heavens eventually the lightning
stopped and the war ended Saturn Mars
and Venus moved into their current
orbits giving us the sky that we know
today
now it's an amazing story but it goes
against everything we've been taught
about gravity the solar system and all
of mainstream cosmology in order for
this Theory to be taken seriously
someone would have to prove it so
someone
did modern science tells us stars are
powered by nuclear fusion at their cores
hydrogen atoms are fused into helium
which produces light and heat scientists
who support the Electra universe theory
disagree they believe electricity plays
a bigger role in the cosmos than
mainstream theory suggest the energy of
the sun is not being driven by Fusion
but by a powerful electric current that
permeates all of space over the past
decade experiments by an international
team called the sapphire project have
put the electric universe theory to the
test their goal recreate the plasma
environment of a star in a laboratory
chamber on Earth um is this a good idea
well it sounds like a fire
[Music]
hazard inside their high-tech facility
in Canada the sapphire team built a
plasma reactor they filled it with low
pressure hydrogen gas which mimics the
early Universe then they introduced an
electrical current creating a glowing
ball of plasma the plasma quickly
self-organized into stable donut shaped
vortices called double layers these
double layers formed electrified shells
that trapped electron and ions and
hydrogen atoms inside okay okay tell me
that again uh but this time pretend I
don't know anything about what you
talking about it made a baby star was
that so
hard the team measured effects within
the reactor never before seen in any lab
on Earth the electron density matched
the measurements made from spacecraft
sent to study the Sun Also the sapphire
plasma sustained enormous electrical
Fields up to 8, ,000 volts per meter but
also a steep droing voltage off the
surface of the plasma which sounds
technical but that's exactly what
happens in the Sun the Reactor Core
reached temperatures of over 880,000 de
C that's hotter than the sun's surface
the plasma thermal radiation was uniform
just like the sun D these doctors must
be so tan I don't see how that's
important da saying it's a good thing
scientists are usually pretty
pasty and then also found evidence of
higher energy in the plasma Corona just
like the sun and it goes on and on the
sapphire project had created their own
mini sun and they did it without nuclear
fusion this was done using only
electricity and most shockingly yeah you
see what you did there the reactor was
changing elements like iron and tungsten
into other elements like magnesium
calcium titanium and 17 others this is a
process called transmutation the
sapphire project had repeatedly
transmuted tungsten and iron into more
than 17 other stable elements all these
phenomena are exactly what the electric
universe theory predicts that stars are
not driven by internal nuclear fusion
after all but by electrical discharges
flowing through Cosmic plasma now more
experiments are needed but the sapphire
reactor hints the ability to pull energy
from the quantum vacuum Nicola Tesla
also believed this was possible if the
sapphire technology works it would leave
lead to unlimited clean energy for the
entire planet ah well those 10
scientists are going to get whacked
before that happens yeah scientists who
try to create free clean energy always
seem to get hit with a lot of bad luck
they also get hit by cars true and
bullets I get
it so we have experiments that validate
the electric universe theory with how
stars are formed and it's an amazing
Discovery but there's one more
experiment we need to do in order to
prove this thing and it's a tricky one
we need to prove Pro that the energy
moving through the cosmic plasma can
move faster than light now Einstein said
this was impossible but it turns out
that Einstein was wrong and last year
somebody proved
it Einstein hated quantum entanglement
what is entanglement this is when two
particles transmit information to each
other faster than the speed of light
really they transmit information faster
than anything and Tangled particles
transmit information instantly no matter
how far apart they are all right I'm
going to try and keep this simple so
physicists don't bother leaving comments
this isn't a video about quantum
mechanics yeah yeah you mena Eggheads
keep your yep shut come on that that's
not nice ah hey you know what Mena
stands for no what my entire night spent
alone
when two particles become entangled
they're now linked now that they're
linked their movement cancels each other
out meaning if particle a is spinning up
then particle B is spinning down this is
called conservation of angular momentum
if one particle is spinning clockwise
the other has to be spinning
counterclockwise make sense yeah I feel
you but remember how weird Quantum
particles
are we don't know what they're doing
until we measure them until they're
measured they're doing everything all at
once and this is called the wave
function now you don't know anything
about a Quantum particle but once you
take a measurement of that particle you
now know everything about it this is the
wave function collapsing the electron
decided to act
differently as though it was aware it
was being
watched now that's weird enough but
entangle two particles and weird becomes
sorcery all right so you've got two
particles that are entangled now you
separate them some distance the
particles can be on separate sides of
your lab or separate sides of the earth
it doesn't matter their length now let's
measure one of those entangled particles
to see if it's spinning up or down again
we don't know what it's doing yet it's
doing its Quantum Voodoo thing it's
spinning up and down at the same
time but when we measure it boom it
State freezes and now we see that it's
spinning up fine that means its partner
must be spinning down we check
yep it's spinning down and the second
particle's wave function also collapsed
though he didn't touch it now let's
separate two intangle particles by a
long
distance we'll put particle a in New
York we'll put particle B on the
moon particle A's wave function
collapses this time it's spinning down
so particle B is spinning up we check
our equipment both particle wave
functions have collapsed at the same
time like the exact same time
but that can't be nothing can move
faster than light light takes 1.28
seconds to get to the moon but that
other particle the one on the moon it
didn't wait 1.28 seconds it collapsed
instantly wait wait wait what now let's
put particle a in Tokyo we put particle
B on Mars collapse particle a boom
particle B collapses too instantly now
on average light takes 12 minutes to
reach Mars the particle didn't wait it
knew its partner in Tokyo collapsed so
it instantly did the same yeah this
can't be real okay last
one we put particle a in London we put
particle B
in the Andromeda galaxy that's about 2
and 1/2 million light years
away we collapsed particle a in London
it takes light 2.5 million years to
reach particle B but particle B doesn't
doesn't wait 2.5 million years to
collapse it doesn't wait 2.5 minutes
particle B 2.5 million light years away
collapses at the same time the same
exact time as the particle in Tokyo and
this is freaking me out well this is
what Einstein hated nothing can move
faster than light so something must be
off so in 1935 Alber Einstein Baris
podowski and Nathan Rosen wrote a paper
saying that quantum mechanics was
incomplete that's why Einstein called it
spooky action at a distance that wasn't
a complement in the paper which became
known as the epr paper Einstein said
that somehow the particle state was
determined before they were measured he
didn't know how he just believed that's
how it worked he called this a hidden
variable the hidden variable has to be
there because nothing can move faster
than
light Einstein believed everything was
local if particles could communicate
instantly over vast distances that means
they're non-local and that makes no
sense and that's how thing stood for
about 30 years then in 1964 John Bell
proposed the thought experiment to show
that entangled particles don't care
about distance they don't care about the
speed of light and they don't care about
Einstein's feelings particles can
communicate instantly no matter the
distance but the cool thing about
Belle's thought experiment was that it
was actually testable in the real world
with real particles in the 1970s
experiments were done that showed Bell
was right and Einstein was
wrong and then in 2022 Alana spect John
clauser and Anton Zinger closed a few
loopholes with the earlier experiments
they proved it in a lab and settle the
argument once and for all Quantum
particles are non-local they can
exchange information instantly they
don't care about distance and they
ignore the speed of light this was so
groundbreaking aspect clauser and xinger
won the Nobel Prize in physics for this
discovery but now here's the big
question how how are the particles
communicating through what medium sound
is the vibration of air molecules air is
the medium Sound Works in water too
water is the medium but sound is slow
wait what' you say but sound is slow
well that really depends on how hard you
squeeze butt sound is
slow you fell for
it radio waves are fast their medium is
the EM spectrum radio waves move at the
speed of light but no fast
what is the medium for Quantum particles
that allows them to communicate
instantly just like the electric
universe theory explains the formation
of galaxies and explains the composition
of the sun it explains this too the
medium is the plasma that fills the
entire universe physicists Nikolai karev
and Nicola Tesla called this The Ether
karev and Tesla both felt that we can
tap into the energy of this ether or
plasma that energy is in water in air in
the vacuum of space it's all around us
this is Zero Point Energy that's why
programs like the sapphire project are
so important and getting more attention
the electric universe theory has been
considered a fringe Theory and this is
why Sapphire conducts a lot of their
work in secret because it's possible
they made the most important Discovery
in history their technology would usher
in an era of prosperity for our
civilization not seen since the last
golden age when Saturn ruled the sky
[Music]
the electric universe theory gets a lot
of science right the electric Universe
answers questions that Einstein couldn't
answer so let's recap the early Universe
was just hydrogen gravity played a role
in compressing the hydrogen into stars
but it was really electricity carried
through Cosmic plasma that fired up the
stars and keeps them going today
according to this Theory 3,500 years ago
Venus emerged from Jupiter as a Comet it
made a few close passes to the Earth and
caused all kinds of Havoc our solar
system was like a billiard table planets
bounced around and eventually settled
into their orbits Saturn once part of a
binary system with the Earth found a new
orbit further out Mars 2 was pushed away
from the earth as the planets moved away
unbelievable lightning arked between
them carving great Canyons like those
seen on Earth and Mars and everywhere
and all of this was documented by our
ancestors in ancient drawings like those
of the cosmic wheel or the stickman with
the two dots finally to test all this
the sapphire project created a ball of
plasma essentially their own mini Sun
their Sun is hot stable and shares all
the characteristics of other large stars
and this is all achieved with
electricity not nuclear fusion and if it
works it's the secret to unlimited free
energy now I love the theory I love the
Legends and I really love the science
but is any of this real well probably
not the truth is Venus was probably
never a comet it's been observed in the
sky as a planet for thousands of years
well before when velkovski said it
emerged from Jupiter speaking of comets
do you remember NASA's epoxy mission in
2005 this is also called Deep Impact
NASA smashed a probe against a comet to
learn about its internal composition
well electric Universe Kingpin W
Thornhill made a lot of predictions
about comets especially this mission he
said there would be arcs of electrical
energy before the impact equipment would
fail x-rays would be emitted along with
bolts of lightning but none of that
happened supporters of the electric
universe theory and there are a lot of
those will point to the predictions that
Thornhill got right though I can't think
of any of those off the top of my head
but those supporters will ignore the
things that he got wrong which was just
about
everything while forign Hill has been
called a physicist and electrical
engineer but I can't find evence
evidence of his credentials anywhere the
only thing we know for sure is that he
was a computer salesman for IBM now
Thornhill was once criticized for not
making his scientific research available
for peer review he said there was no
need to he had no peers no cocky I like
it and all the ancient myth connections
to the cosmic wheel and all that stuff
about Saturn that was all cherry-picked
our ancient ancestors were aware of
Saturn for thousands of years Rings
weren't discovered until 1610 by Galileo
but the planet was out there
way out there the sapphire project is
also suspicious until their data is
shared and their experiments confirmed
by other scientists we have to assume
their plasma reactor doesn't work so so
it's a fraud well if their machine
showed even the smallest possibility
that it might work they'd be swimming in
billions of dollars but they're not
they're constantly looking for money but
I wouldn't say the sapphire project is a
fraud but LOL Morgan would when Sapphire
was launched Dr L Morgan was the only
plasma physicist on the team and he
wasn't impressed he exchanged a few
emails with science YouTuber Professor
Dave about his experience the EU concept
is fraudulent being promoted by
several people as real science to the
general public they don't really know
any physics or mathematics to speak of
they have all the usual trappings of
crackpot scientists Dr Morgan eventually
left the project I quit for several
reasons one they could no longer pay me
and two they're just am
and I was tired of working with amateurs
they're bozos so why would a legitimate
scientist get involved with this in the
first place it all began with velikovsky
I read worlds in Collision in 1960 and
thought it was a great yarn but any
implied physics was wrong the electric
universe theory is considered pseudo
science but you know how I feel about
that word but sometimes pseudo science
plus time equal
science
[Music]
the prejudging scorn and closing of
ranks against the heretic showed typical
Guild
animus in recent years however evidence
collected during the geophysical year
and by several space probes has tended
to verify several of fov's predictions
for instance he had said in the face of
strong disagreement that because of her
recent birth Venus is extremely hot a
view subsequently borne out by
observations of Mariner to
he was accused of inventing an
interplanetary magnetic field but one
has been detected since then by Pioneer
5 he claimed in 1950 that the ancient
civilizations of Central America were
much older than believed recently this
view too has been proved by radiocarbon
dating as you know I try to find all
sides to a story if I can and whenever I
cover alternate science I also give the
point of view of the Skeptics but that's
with this episode when I started to get
upset some of the videos I found that
debunk the electric universe theory are
aggressive if you're open-minded to an
idea like the electric Universe then
According to some YouTube scientists
you're a you're a nut job you're a
toddler if a snake oil scientist is
taking advantage of people by charging
them money for nonsense then call them
out I support that 100% but attacking
the Believers the victims I don't agree
with that at all you persuade with
compassion and kindness not with insult
and condescension and there are other
debunkers who think belovsky Thornhill
and other proponents of the electric
universe theory should be silenced and
that their research should be removed
from the internet this is to protect us
from you guessed it disin information
right protecting people from
disinformation is censorship and there's
no place for that in
science LLY was the scientific quests
caring at him and in a way that was
violent not in terms of an orderly
discussion that this idea is yet to be
tested and it takes more time and Etc
but saying this idea is crazy and any
man who has such an idea is mad insane
that kind of thing but the establishment
through which men who think that way
make a living the academic establishment
was saying to this man you know you're
not
Sav scientists tried to censor
velikovsky too bov's book worlds in
Collision was a New York Times
bestseller the science ific community
did everything they could to remove it
from the charts and eventually they
succeeded the the book The World's in
Collision then merely the first of the
books had been on the top of the
bestseller list for something like 11
weeks and nonetheless the publisher was
so um mortally wounded as the only word
by
the the uh Turning Away of salesmen from
the doors of of professor's studies and
all of the implications that went with
this that the book was transferred to
another publisher which was willing to
take it over which after all is a fairly
extraordinary thing bossk's ideas were
too dangerous we had to be protected
from disinformation so poof the book is
gone and look velikovsky was probably
wrong about everything the comet Venus
Saturn the electric Sun all of it
probably all wrong but it's okay to be
wrong that's how we find out the truth
in the words of a great scientist
science is a self-correcting process to
be accepted new ideas must survive the
most rigorous standards of evidence and
scrutiny the worst aspect of the vovi
affair is not that uh many of his ideas
were wrong or silly or in Gross
contradiction to the facts rather the
worst aspect is that some scientists
attempted to suppress volkov's
ideas
scientific ideas must survive the most
rigorous standards of evidence or
scrutiny well scrutiny means your theory
has to withstand aggressive debate take
climate change no such thing well don't
be a sheep the climate is warming
up but is it happening quickly no I
don't know some scientists say no is
there anything humans can do to stop it
no I don't know some scientists say no
there are two sides to this scientific
debate but only one side is allowed to
be heard that's not science that's
censorship now I don't know who's right
neither do you but who cares I just want
to know the truth don't you the
suppression of uncomfortable ideas may
be common in religion or in politics but
it is not the path to knowledge and
there's no place for it in the Endeavor
of
science now what about certain
experimental medicines that a lot of us
have been taking those medications work
well for most people but not all people
but we don't hear much about that there
are two sides to this issue as well but
there's no debate allowed look I can't
even say the v-word on this platform now
that's not science that's censorship
science is now used to give more wealth
to the wealthy science is used to give
more power to the powerful and science
is now weaponized to turn half the
country against the other again I don't
care who's right I just want the truth
but science isn't about truth not
anymore promote the right science and
get a book deal a guest spot on cable
news and highly paid speaking
engagements promote the wrong science
lose your reputation lose your career
get deplatformed on social media what
would you choose so scientists without
accepted and conventional ideas stopped
asking questions and the history of our
study of the solar system shows clearly
that accepted and conventional ideas are
often wrong and that fundamental
insights can arise from the most
unexpected
sources Carl Sean was correct accepted
science is often wrong so here's
something to keep in the back of your
mind when there's a mainstream
scientific view out there that
suppresses debate and censors scientists
that disagree that mainstream scientific
view exists for money and for power not
for the truth and on that there is no
debate
this episode of the Y files is brought
to you by the Y files operation podcast
deep Dives and longer stories every
week thank you so much for hanging out
with us today my name is AJ there's
Heckle fish Ola this has been the W
files if you had fun or learned anything
do him a favor subscribe comment like
share that stuff really helps the
channel and like every topic we cover
here on the yfiles today's was
recommended by you so if there's a story
you'd like to see or learn more about go
to the Wi files.com / tips and if like
me you're sad at the end of every
episode check out the wi files Discord
it's free to join there's thousands of
people on there and 24/7 there's
somebody talking about something weird
and something fun and special thanks to
our patrons who make the channel
possible every episode is dedicated to
you and I can't thank you enough for
your generosity now if you'd like to
support the channel consider becoming a
member on patreon for as little as $3 a
month you keep the channel going you get
access to videos early without
commercials Early Access to fun products
like the Heckle fish talking plushy and
two extra live streams a week just for
you another great way to support the
channel is grab something from the wif
file store go grab yourself a heck ofish
t-shirt and stick your fist in one of
these fist mugs or get one of these
Heckle fish tet fish animal fish Styles
that's going to do it until next time be
safe be kind and know that you are
[Music]
appreciated
oh oh
yeah I play B inara 51 a secret code
inside the Bible said I
was I love my UFOs and paranormal fun as
well as music so singing like I
should but then another conspiracy
theory becomes the truth my friend ends
and it never
ends no it never
[Music]
ends I feel the crap gu got stuck inside
M's hole with MK truck I being only true
aware did Stanley Cube brick fake the
moon landing alone on a film set I with
the shadow
there the r well aliens just fought the
smiling man I'm
told and his name was
cold I can't believe I'm dancing with
the
fish thday night Wednesday
J through the
night all I ever wanted was to just hear
the truth so the up through the
[Music]
night the MTH man SIDS and the solar
storm still come to have got the the
secret City
Underground mysterious number stations
Planet Sero to project Star Gate and
where the dark Watchers
[Music]
found a simulation don't you
wor the black knack satellited to me so
I can't believe I'm dancing with the
fish heck fish on Thursday nights with
they
J me all through the
night
all I ever wanted was to just hear the
truth so the Fe all through the
night fish on Thursday night Wednesday J
and through the
night all I ever wanted was to just hear
the truth so the time feat all through
the
good love to dance good love to dance
good love to
dance to
dance loves to
dance loves to dance on the dance
because she is a camel and camels love
to dance when the feeling is right on W
in
time
love SC love
[Music]
and